make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
hello everyone it is Christmas week at
the time that we're recording this video
and I imagine a lot of you guys are
gonna be opening presents and you're
gonna be doing after Christmas shopping
and so we're gonna keep it a pretty
light week I'm gonna be out of town
actually for pretty much the entirety of
Christmas week almost going up to up to
New Year's Eve and so I figured we kind
of go back to the to the old school form
of Commerce explained if only for this
week and basically explained nothing but
characters this do a whole bunch of
character explanations and because we
don't really have a whole lot of
character exclamations on BC in this
video we're gonna explain Kyle Rayner
the Green Lantern so Kyle Weiner made
his debut in DC Comics back in Green
Lantern vol 3 issue number 48 in January
of 1944 and he was created by ron mars
and daryl banks now a little bit of
history here because kyle rayner was
really the byproduct of DC not really
hard rebooting the Green Lantern mythos
but really more soft rebooting it now
honestly what that means here in a
second but a little bit history here
people look at the events of crisis on
Infinite Earths and they see it as
strictly a hard reboot and indeed it was
right I mean it was the first time that
DC had basically relaunched their entire
landscape with new origin stories and
all that kind of stuff but the reality
of crisis on Infinite Earths and the
reason why you got future events like
zero our crisis in time Infinite Crisis
Final Crisis is because one there were a
lot of continuity errors that came after
it but the lion's share of what was
supposed to happen with with the post
crisis landscape is that DC would look
at that landscape and they would say
okay after we've rebooted and we've
drawn all this attention and we're
getting a ton of sales what do people
really want to see and so it was gauging
what kind of comics were selling by just
kind of looking at what people were
buying and calling it a day
the result of this is that when DC
looked at Green Lantern Hal Jordan just
wasn't really a bankable character and
that was something that I kind of been
established during Dennis O'Neil and
Neal Adams run as great as it was when
Hal Jordan and Green Arrow were
basically backup features in the flash
comics they couldn't hold their own
comic because they're comic wasn't
selling and so as a result of that when
I got around to you know 1994 after the
death of Superman which I always
considered to be an unofficial crisis
due to all the things that were changed
as a result of that story DC basically
said okay let's rework the entirety of
the Green Lantern mythos so what you got
was a story called Green Lantern Emerald
Twilight and emerald Twilight was
designed to follow off the heels of the
Death of Superman with Hal Jordan
returning from a mission in space only
to find out the coast city had been
totally destroyed and so using his ring
in a way that wasn't officially
sanctioned by the by the guardians of
the universe and in fact was frowned
upon and this
to use it for personal gain by
essentially recreating Coast City and
all the people in it who was ultimately
brought before the Guardians and then
was essentially chastised for his
actions this of course results into Hal
Jordon he was already brokenhearted
essentially losing his mind going crazy
killing all the Guardians except for
ganthet and a whole host of the Green
Lantern's they clearly liked Sinestro
and Kilowog and so on and then basically
christening himself parallax and going
forward from there the result of this is
that Kyle Rayner was introduced as a new
and younger and more vibrant version of
Green Lantern now the funny thing about
this is that Ron Mars did an interview
with coming book resources back in 2003
when he was talking about his taking
onto the book and the reason why I did
that that interview and others is
because his time on Green Lantern or at
least when he took over was highly
divisive among fans you know fans were
very very divided about it because some
looked at it and said yes it's time for
a change Hal Jordan is just old hat
where are the other people who were very
much attached to Hal Jordan didn't want
to see things change and so the result
was that you kind of had this splitting
of the Green Lantern fan base some of
whom loved what Ron Mars did and others
hated what Ron Mars did but regardless
of the circumstance Ron Mars was
ultimately just kind of given the Green
Lantern vote with issue number 47
literally he got a phone call on like
Friday night by Kevin Dulli who is the
editor of Green Lantern at the time he
got a call on Friday night so do you
want the Green Lantern book and and Ron
Maher said yes because our huge Green
Lantern fan and he was like okay here's
the partial scripts for like issues 46
47 48 have had it and so he had like
these insane deadlines that he had to
make and it was it was kind of it was
kind of crazy but the fact remains that
with Ron Mars taking over for Kyle
Rayner Kyle was have basically visited
by ganthet and ganthet essentially said
hey look you're essentially the last of
the real Green Lantern's now guys like
Jon Stewart and guys like Guy Gardner
were still around the difference is that
because it was a reworking of the Green
Lantern mythos they were removed from
the Green Lantern Corps you ended up
having Jon Stewart joined a group called
the dark Stars and Guy Gardner actually
ended up losing his power ring in a
battle against Hal Jordan and then he'd
really kind of gained a new type of
power in the form of his warrior persona
and we'll go more into that once where
once we get into like Guy Gardner
explained but when Ron Marz took over
the story's the idea was that he didn't
simply want to just throw a new Green
Lantern out there right because when it
comes to come up fans we grow attached
to characters the longer that we read
them and the more that we identify with
him and so you know recognizing the the
idea of how Jordan being removed would
not really sit well with a lot of
existing Green Lantern fans the notion
was that while emerald Twilight
basically saw the collapse
the core Hal Jordan becoming parallax
now is really the end of him the
introduction of a new Green Lantern had
to be done in such a way to where fans
wanted to identify with him or their
passing interest about him would turn
into the idea of well let's see where
this goes right you know continuing
interest that would that would go beyond
the first handful of issues and so what
you got between issues number 48 and 51
really in the span of these three comics
is you got this wholesale introduction
of who Kyle Rayner was what he was
capable of and how he learned how to use
his powers and the reality is that rod
Mars borrowed heavily from the concept
of Lana Lang and the Superman comics as
well as the Gwen Stacy's the death of
Gwen Stacy in the night Gwen Stacy died
from Jerry Conway in 1971 and the reason
why I say this is because for the
Superman mythos those guys who were
familiar with it Lana Lang was the was
the the Smallville childhood friend of
Clark Kent and was the first person to
learn about his powers at least so if
you go based on the Jeff John secret
origin and then in turn she was the one
that helped him navigate the waters on
how to use those abilities in much the
same way Alexander do went was
introduced in issue number 48 as the
girlfriend of Kyle Rayner and so the
idea was that that where cow waiter
himself was really kind of having this
devil-may-care attitude the sense that
he was reckless he never really seemed
to take himself or anything he really
did seriously and this was really a
problem for Alexander because it was
kind of a thing of learn to take
yourself seriously right I mean if you
ever want to make make anything out of
yourself in this world you have to
become a more serious person and so over
the course of these three issues she
taught him basically how to use his
abilities the idea that what Gant had
said is that the ring can essentially
allow him to create any construct he
wants you wants to and there's no limit
to his imagination there's this
hilarious moment actually an issue
number 51 where they're standing on the
beach and uh and unless she's like we'll
create something as we creates her as a
green lantern construct in like this
super thin string bikini but basically
Ron Marz used this as a way to introduce
the idea that Kyle Rayner was beyond Hal
Jordan in so far asked what he could
construct using his ring right because
how Jordan constructed like boxing
gloves are like a giant fist or a hand
or something like that and that was
really it was pretty limited because Hal
Jordan really kind of the the stories
maintained the original 1950s element of
just something interesting and
intriguing there's easily identifiable
but nothing overly complicated hence one
of the reasons why Hal Jordan never
really seemed to succeed beyond the
stories in the 1950s but under these
three issues or in these three issues
under on Mars we started learning things
that Kyle Rayner could create like anime
like mecha constructs these super super
advanced constructs and ways that we
hadn't really seen before crafting a
green lantern suit for himself that was
in a lot of ways start Li different from
the suit that Hal Jordan had worn it was
basically taking these three issues and
even going into issue 52 and 53 and
saying this is not your granddad's green
lantern this is a whole different beast
and so this really kind of came to a
head and issue number 54 when the gwen
stacy concept was taken by Ron Marz and
thrown into the comics and it really
pissed off a lot of fans who had already
began to latch on and the reason why is
because that's kind of of fans and this
is something I've been guilty of in the
past but one of the things that we
usually end up doing is oftentimes we
put ourselves in the role of the
character that were reading right so
like for people who were fans of how
later they imagine themselves living
Kyle Raynor's life a byproduct of this
is that Kyle Rainer's love-interest
Alexander do it became the love interest
of the fans who were reading his comics
and so in issue number 54 of Green
Lantern vol 3 basically Alexandre de Wit
was killed by a villain a major force
when she was struck a stucked at a
refrigerator now the reality of Ron Marz
is he was taking the gwen stacy concept
right and so far that where the death of
okhla been basically taught spider-man
that he has to be responsible with the
powers that he has the death of when
Stacy taught spider-man he can't be
reckless with his powers and that's
exactly how this played out with Kyle
Rayner and so the death of Alexander do
it really coincided with Ron Marz kind
of picking up some loose threads or at
the very least adapted them to the new
Green Lantern story in terms of the
villain Mangal uh who was seeking
revenge on both Superman as well as
Green Lantern following his defeat in
the events leading up to emerald
twilight after the death of Superman as
well as songul aligning himself with
major force and so the result of this is
that issue number 54 of course again saw
Alexander duet being stuffed in a
refrigerator effectively being killed
and that allowed Ron Mars to move a cow
later away from not only Los Angeles but
from his reckless attitude traveling to
New York and then falling closer in line
and really becoming a tried-and-true
superhero in the DC Comics landscape as
opposed to a sort of outlier and what I
mean by that is between 1994 and 2002
there were a lot of changes going on in
DC Comics at the time but because Kyle
Rayner was basically being brought
closer in line with a superhero
superhero landscape who was essentially
a part of all of them during 1994 zero
hour crisis and time war by Hal Jordan
as parallax tried to essentially rewrite
all of reality to make it a more
peaceful place Kyle Rayner alongside the
then Justice League at the time the
Justice League international team
written by J M DeMatteis and and Keith
given essentially
and saw the defeat of Hal Jordan
ultimately uh he ended up meeting Jade
the daughter of Alan Scott who alongside
the rest of the JSA had returned during
1992 Armageddon Inferno event fell in
love with Jade after the two of them had
become roommates in New York there are a
lot of things that were taking place at
the time but one of the most notable
things that came out of this really took
place as part of the events both with
final night as well as the return of Jay
LA and then initially ion now what I
mean here is that the JLA team had
basically returned in 1997 under Grant
Morrison with the official Reformation
of the original Justice League of
America team from the old 1950s and 60s
really from 1960 going forward in the
post-crisis landscape something that was
highly celebrated by a lot of existed in
DC fans Kyle Rayner being brought
directly onto the team was exceedingly
important because up to that point he
had appeared in Aquaman Comics and some
Deathstroke comics and DC had spread him
around
but outside of his own Green Lantern
book and whatever appearances he made
was part of the Titans team from 1994
with issue numbers 116 his relationship
with Donna Troy that was all you really
got but putting him on JLA effectively
meant that he was officially a member of
the Justice League and officially one of
the top tier heroes something that
existing Green Lantern fans who enjoyed
the enjoy the concept of Kyle Rayner
highly loved at the same time in 1986
she basically had a story called final
night and final night for its part well
I did have a great big huge involvement
with tons of superheroes and various
individuals out there you had a villain
called Sun ear and the story itself was
really more to kind of wrap up the plot
threads of Hal Jordan insofar as he just
kind of been lingering there ever since
the events of emerald Twilight the story
essentially saw himself quote-unquote
sacrificing his life in order to absorb
the sun-eater and his ring was
essentially left inside the Sun itself
now he would return in 1999 during days
of judgment and ultimately end up
becoming the spectre but during that
point in time because of the fact that
his ring was essentially left behind
there was a story that was written that
was called the circle of fire that was
done I think it might as well but
basically focus on the idea of the
introduction of a villain named oblivion
and what you ended up getting here was
Kyle Rayner facing off against this guy
along with the Justice League who was
captured and at the end of the story you
basically learned that oblivion along
with the other Green Lantern's
quote-unquote that had been brought in
from other realities were really more
just fact similes of the various
personal struggles of Kyle Rayner had
dealt with and the various aspects of
his personality and so as a result of
that the Green Lantern's were ultimately
reabsorbed into himself
oblivion was defeated the JLA was saved
and these
two blocks in the mind of Kyle later
were released and what it meant was that
this combined with the events of final
night basically allowing him to tap into
you and absorb the remaining energy of
Hal Jordans ring left in the Sun
essentially meant the Kyle Rayner they
came a wholly new character now that
took place in issue number 146 of green
lantern the reality was that Ron Mars as
Ron had finished with issue 125 issues
126 127 128 were taken over by Jay Faber
for a little three issue temporary run
more or less in order for DC to
basically find a new rider and have them
take over Judd Winick had basically
taken over with issue number 129 but
when the issue of 146 in the idea of
Kyle Rayner becoming becoming ion it was
a whole new echelon of power meaning he
was doing things the Green Lantern's had
never done before right so being able to
be in multiple places at once the guy
was in effect god the problem with this
was that by the time you've got to 2000
and you got even into 2002 the idea was
that DC wanted to essentially kind of
bring Green Lantern back right you had
geoff johns who was already on the scene
following his short tenure writing The
Avengers in more comics and the idea was
let's bring the entire team back but the
question became how would they end up
returning Infinite Crisis was a concept
that was being worked on but Infinite
Crisis wouldn't come to fruition until
2006 and Final Crisis wouldn't come to
fruition until 2009 and so what you
ended up getting was basically this the
series of events were written in such a
way to where during his time as ion you
essentially had Kyle Rayner come to this
realization that it was too much power
for one man to handle right it was just
too much for one individual to have
because ultimately it would lead to his
downfall in the same way that Hal Jordan
ended up falling down as a result of him
becoming parallax and so over the course
of the next 30 issues with Judd Winick
basically beginning the process of
stepping down in order for Ron Mars to
come back in and wrap up Green Lantern
vol 3 you saw two major events take
place the first is that I on or I guess
Kyle Rayner as I on I had essentially
dispersed those energies and recreated
the Green Lantern central power battery
what this did was bring back the
guardians of the universe who in turn
created new Green Lantern rings and then
brought the Green Lantern Corps back
when the rings were dispersed across the
cosmos the second event that had taken
place is that Kyle Rayner hidden in a
fighting major force and then ultimately
because of how the battle had gone in
the sense that Kyle Rayner had let his
anger get the better of him considered
himself to be a danger to everybody that
he cared about and then left for the far
reaches of space and so what this did
was segue directly into the events of
Green Lantern rebirth the return of Hal
his soul essentially being returned to
his physical body uh since he'd only
been lingering around as the spectre
following the events of day of judgment
and really his quote-unquote death more
or less during the final night event and
then Kyle Reiter himself returning after
learning the truth about parallax and
with this basically coming as Jeff
John's taking over the Green Lantern
story everything began to shift in his
entirety the Green Lantern mythos was
expanded in ways that nobody had ever
really considered before and what I mean
by that is up to that point the idea of
the yellow impurity which is to say the
weakness of the Green Lantern's were
simply just a concept that was there and
it had never really been fully explored
right it was just the Green Lantern's
are weak to the color yellow done and
that was really all it was when it when
it came to that mythos Jeff Jones
introduced the idea of lantern entities
in the sense that the reason why Green
Lantern's are weak to the color yellow
is because at some point in time the
fear entity parallax had been imprisoned
inside the Green Lantern central power
battery and was kept there by the being
ion by the entity of the Green Lantern's
itself and so with parallax being stuck
inside the ring parallax representing
fear and fear being yellow Green
Lantern's were susceptible to fear
because it was like introducing an ink
stain into water right it just kind of
spread throughout everything and if
given enough time if not kept at bay
then it would basically spread
throughout the entire core so that was
the entire basis behind the idea of the
yellow impurity but for cow Vader
himself the truth about this is that for
the most part under Jeff Jones run he
became a background character not in the
sense that he was being ignored for the
most part when it came to Jeff Jones
taking over Green Lantern the first
thing to do was to expand the mythos the
second thing was to drive up interest by
introducing other Lantern cores kind of
tying in the emotional spectrum insofar
as the other Lantern cores are based on
the emotional spectrum so the origins of
the red lanterns and the Indigo tribe
and so on and so forth and then of
course to focus on Hal Jordan as the
main Green Lantern of Earth he was the
most popular version of the Green
Lantern's that resided on earth leading
up to of courses death in the
introduction of Kyle Rayner and so it
made sense to focus on him as the main
character of the story now for Kyle
himself one of the big things that came
out of it as Kyle basically became home
to the the entity ion the entity of the
Green Lantern's and this was really kind
of the return of ion to is what a lot of
people refer to it as but again the idea
was that for the Sinestro Corps war as
that event broke out it was to strip the
ion entity from Kyle Rayner to basically
study at in the antimatter universe this
basically led calibrator to going back
and becoming the original Green Lantern
to remove from the
of what was called the torchbearer
meaning he was housing the ion entity
sort of if the Green Lantern Corps was
ever destroyed he would be able to
recreate it again all these little
things had kind of been introduced and
then removed look how later himself just
kind of not really free floated but just
sort of went throughout the Green
Lantern stories and took part in various
events that went down but was by no
means the main focal point of Green
Lantern however the idea of Geoff Johns
putting Kyle on the back burner was sort
of revealed for what it was in the pre
luda rise of the Third Army coming after
the war of the Green Lantern's and the
idea here was that Geoff Johns had
planned for Kyle Rayner insofar as as
part of this preliterate least as part
of the story what you got was the idea
that seemingly one ring from all the
other Lantern course came out of nowhere
and all tried to bond themselves
directly to Kyle Rayner and what it did
is it set the stage for the idea of Kyle
being the only Green Lantern to ever
really wield all of the Lantern rings up
to that point in time now it was only
temporary it didn't last for an
exceedingly long period of time and in
fact all the Rings had basically been
destroyed with the exception of the
green and the orange ring only for us to
find out the Orangery was basically a
construct that needed the help of Kyle
Rayner but once you went into the
aftermath of the the rise of the Third
Army storyline what you got was these
kind of trials of Kyle and so far that
if all these different rings had chosen
Kyle Rayner then what he needed to do
was become a master of the Rings in
order to be able to utilize all the
Rings effectively and so you didn't have
seen these scenarios where like the
trosset is for example was trying to get
Kyle Rayner to the point where he was so
pissed off and would be a avatar or a
bearer of sorts for the Red Lantern ring
which in turn would allow Kyle to master
the Red Lantern ring and then basically
use his power without succumbing to his
influence and it fell the exact same way
with pretty much all the Rings - the
Green Lantern because he was already a
Green Lantern at one point in time and
had already mastered its willpower as
well following this going into the wrath
of the first Lantern storyline and then
going into lights out and a handful of
stories from there you basically ended
up seeing this kind of transformation of
Kyle where he went from just a guy who
was a Green Lantern at one point in time
to a guy who could use the power of all
the Lantern rings for his own ends and
then in turn helped the various heroes
across the universe now John's was very
very careful about this right because if
he had mishandled this it would have
turned it to the Franklin Richards
effect right if Franklin Richards is so
powerful then why is it he just fix
everything that's wrong with him all the
universe whenever an event crops up it's
the same name question people would have
had about Kyle
he's a Green Lantern or if he's a
lantern that can essentially wield all
of the lantern rings then why doesn't he
just use all the Lantern rings to fix
everything and so that's one of the
reasons why Jeff Johnson introduced the
idea of weaknesses within the various
Lantern rings the idea that the
carburetor could use them but there are
still limitations to all the things that
he was able to pull off and so going
into lights out what you ended up
getting was Kyle using his rings to
essentially help the various cores
across the universe face off against
relic this being from a different
universe who believe the emotional
spectrum would lead to the destruction
of the of the main DC Universe and
attempted to essentially destroy the
emotional spectrum itself the reality
was that this basically led to cau
Raynor enforces essentially defeating
relic the day more or less being say
this of course goes into the launch of
the new 52 it basically went into Kyle
Rayner essentially believing to have
been dead the idea was of the various
entities had essentially sacrificed
themselves to what was whatever was
beyond the source wall and that was
essentially it right Kyle Rayner along
with relic had traveled to the source
wall relic had been trapped inside the
wall but how Waner had passed through
and where everybody believed that car
Waner had moved on to the afterlife Kyle
Rayner ultimately ended up returning to
the new guardians and the results of
this was that given the nature of Kyle
Rayner given the power he possessed and
what he was capable of that ultimately
his his return had to be kept a secret
as the what I did is it allowed Jeff
John's a kind of Usher Kyle Rayner off
to the side have him more or less become
space Jesus because that's literally
what he looked like
you know allowed him to become space
Jesus and pretty much all the other
aspects of his life have been left
behind his one-time relationship with
cirrhotic nachi which ultimately broke
up for cirrhotic not to being the
daughter of Sinestro all these things
had really kind of become aspects of his
life that were no longer valid anymore
he was really just traveling across the
universe creating life experimenting
with life different things like that but
more or less calling it a day now
because Carl Reiner's would have existed
as like you know being able to harness
the power of the white light of this
white Lantern ring or what have you
because the power was too extreme now
basically dispersed the ring among six
other individuals so that if a time of
her came when he had to utilize the full
totality of the white light power he
could recall all the rings to himself
and basically a place whenever that
threat happened to be the issue with
this is that DC was basically gearing up
for the launch of DC rebirth right we
basically concluded with Darkseid work
things were essentially wrapping up the
idea of going into this relaunch of DC
Comics in a way that would essentially
drive interest back up again but also
see the return of a lot of the things
that people miss from the new 52 that
they wanted to see brought back what you
ended up getting with
Rober Venditti essentially taking over
the green lantern line of comics after
Geoff Johns and the issue with Kyle
Rayner is kind of like this messianic
character was that you couldn't really
do anything with it we couldn't really
ride a character with that level of
power and how they faced off against
anything but like these massive threats
but at the end of the day people wanted
to see Kyle Rayner return and so what
ended up happening here is is that
through a series of events Powell later
had basically brought back Hal Jordan
essentially from limbo or the afterlife
of purgatory or whatever you want to
call it and then tried to recreate the
Blue Lantern Corps which had been
destroyed during the events of the story
with relic of the lights-out event and
so as a result of that what ended up
happening here is where Kyle Rayner had
tried to reach out and recreate the Blue
Lantern court some external force
basically destroyed the ring now given
the fact that this coincided with the
launch of Doomsday Clock and the idea
that dr. Manhattan was essentially in
the DC universe it all stood the reason
that dr. Manhattan was the one who would
essentially stopped Kyle Rayner and
destroyed the white Lantern's in the
process or at least the white Lantern
power in the process but regardless of
how you look at it the result was at
Cowell Raina was basically returned to
going back to being a Green Lantern
again following that there were a series
of stories that were told by Robert
Venditti but again it was really more of
focusing on the entirety of the Green
Lantern Corps as opposed to a singular
set of events one of the most notable
things that came out of that was Kyle
and her son are really the son of
himself and and cirrhotic not too from
the future had basically come to the
past and Kyle Rayner was ultimately
forced to destroy him but the idea
behind this is that where Kyle Rayner
and Sonic had essentially reformed their
relationship more or less and were
ceramic Knotts who had led the the
Sinestro Corps following the death of
Sinestro during the opening story of
Robert VIN duties run what you ended up
getting was this realization that with
their future son having been destroyed
by Kyle and the fact that it was a it
was kept a secret from cirrhotic this
basically instilled a rift in them that
was really almost incurable insofar as
cirrhotic not who basically said the the
Sinestro Corps and the Green Lantern
Corps will no longer be working together
we're leaving they went off to their own
sector of space while it seemed like
they wouldn't really return to their old
ways under Sinestro which is to say
traveling around the universe and just
instilling fear everywhere they found it
the rift between Kyle and and sonic
expanded out to the core and basically
said there would be no more interaction
between the Green Lantern's and the
Sinestro if one crossed the other they
would end up going into war right so it
was more or less one of those you stay
away we stay away kind of scenarios and
it sort of went forward from there the
issue with this is that Robert VIN Dedes
ron was pretty much as good as Jeff
John's run
it was an amazing win of the green
lantern but following everything that
had gone on so far what you ended up
getting was just this reworking of the
Green Lantern under Grant Morrison which
I have not been reading at the moment I
don't really think we have an
explanation of what's going on with Kyle
Rayner or where he stands um I haven't
really seen him in the Justice League
stories by Scott Snyder DC kind of seems
to be all over the place whether or not
things will shift back to Kyle Rayner in
a way that we're familiar with I'm not
entirely sure but at the moment Kyle
Rayner has really stood as one of the
most popular Green Lantern's following
his introduction and while he was the
frontrunner for a time of course going
into Green Lantern rebirth he sort of
fell back to the background and really
became a background character for time
with Geoff Johns focusing more on how
Jordan as opposed to specifically cow
Vader himself though would that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come as
explain and make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys want my uncensored and
verses videos as well as live Q&A s and
all kinds of stuff make sure you guys go
check out patreon.com/crashcourse
explain I want to give a shout out to
Jason see Austin s Jason s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B as well as Steven Z
Eagle F Joey M and Jeff are as well as
Genesis 916 as always we just usually
keep the last name - an initial it helps
you guys to maintain your anonymity some
of you guys were expressed concerned
about having like your first and last
name thrown out there for the world to
see I do not blame you for you guys who
have joined up as part of our patreon
tiers that are eligible for Rob for
honor guard rings those whose rings have
been sent out you should already have
them if you're a new person who just
joined up and you've been part of this -
here for a month your ring will be
mailed out to you so I want to say thank
you guys for being patrons
[Music]
try